[Music]
hello
and welcome to drugs death and hypocrisy
my name's marianne sicard alcohol and
tobacco are the drugs of choice for much
of the western world
yet they're remarkably deadly the who
estimates that tobacco alone kills eight
million people a year now that's
more than the number that have died from
covid in the past year
yet at the same time western nations
have carried out a war on the
recreational drugs of other countries
such as cocaine cannabis and heroin by
the centuries sometimes with boots on
the ground
with legal and economic barriers so
should we end this hypocrisy by
recognizing the dangers of alcohol and
tobacco
and ceasing to export them to other
nations or more radically perhaps by
making them illegal
should we accept that the policy is
economically unjust and irrational
and allowed trade and recreational drugs
at whatever time
or evan nation well we've got a
fantastic panel to discuss this today
david nutt i'm sure we've all heard of
is an esteemed neuropsychopharmacologist
and former drug star he's a leading
authority on drugs and alcohol
who was actually sacrament drugs for
saying quite accurately that
taking ecstasy is less dangerous than
riding a horse
you safe limit of alcohol would be one
glass of wine a year
so my evening's ruined then uh deirdre
mccloskey is distinguished professor
emerita of
economics history english and
communication at the university of
illinois
she's a renowned libertarian economist
and writer and she describes herself as
a
post-modern free market quantitative
episcopalian
feminist aristotelian and
peter schuster hughes is a rising star
of psychedelic philosophy
known as the psychedelic nietzsche he's
a research fellow at the university of
exeter
the author of pneumoniatics and and i
think has caps it all he's the
inspiration for a marvel superhero
carnac so the question is is the west
hypocritical in its treatment of drugs
alcohol and tobacco
and if so what should be done to end the
hypocrisy
it's david nutt we'll start with you one
of the things i like to do and i'm
talking to undergraduates i i'm a
professor at imperial college london
and i ask them how is this great
university funded
and they say oh i don't know railways
coal and i say no selling opium to the
chinese
and selling cannabis to the indians and
they
because of course people forget that so
the british empire was the largest drug
dealer that was ever known
[Music]
but now for the now as a result of
political changes and international
pressure particularly the usa
the drugs we used to make our money from
are now illegal and we prosecute people
for
using them uh whereas we celebrate the
uh
access to drugs like alcohol and tobacco
largely because
those businesses have become rather
sophisticated in manipulating our
politicians
so as as you intimated at the beginning
i've
researched and given government's advice
about drugs for quite a few years and
telling the truth of governments about
the comparative harms of drugs is a
rather fruitless
exercise because governments don't want
to know and that
the fact they don't want to know proves
that the policies are hypocritical
dishonest not evidence-based and should
be dramatically overhauled
both nationally and internationally
thank you
dear mccloskey well i i have
as an economist as a
chicago school economist in some ways
i'm very s empathetic with the idea
of treating people
as adults as against
sad or bad
children and so my own
view of this is yes of course the west
and
the east and the north and the south are
hypocritical humans are
and and on that score i think that
we should abolish all the drug laws on
alcohol
on to tobacco
and on anything else you
would would in in
you think you would enjoy ingesting i
don't think there's
any political philosophical case
for extra taxation on alcohol
or
prohibition of marijuana or whatever
on the grounds of oh it hurts you
you know i don't exercise enough does
that mean
that the government should
arouse me at six o'clock in the morning
and
bring us all out for
group exercise so if we're going to
follow
the great principle of
john stewart mill and adam smith i
always cross myself
i mentioned adam smith i'm an anglican
so
you know this is a serious matter um
we should treat people as grown-ups
not as children
so peter um well yes i suppose
to answer your question i do think it's
hypocritical or rather it's sort of
irrational and unscientific the
prohibition of
certain drugs as opposed to certain
others i think the reason
for the prohibition of certain drugs is
mostly well it can be traced
historically
if you look for example at the um
the conquistadors those who colonize the
americas you see that the
relation the approach they had to peyote
and you know psilocybin in in the in the
magic mushrooms there um
was one of um suppression
due to a christian general framework or
roman catholic framework
um it was said by a number of jesuits
there that um
such drugs would um give you access to
the devil
and that they were harmful there were
some actually who talked about the
medicinal value and so on and so forth
but nonetheless we see the prohibition
starting there and later on puritans
coming to northern america
had their own reasons for prohibition
but also of course alcohol you know
alcohol was banned in america
in the early 20th century as we all know
didn't work out um
gave rise to cocktails i believe and so
on um
and and then and then as we um go into
the sort of early ninth well 19th and
early 20th centuries we see that
at least psychedelics the drugs that i'm
mostly interested in they were
really um confined to the intellectual
and artistic sphere you know
borderland um and then people like
william james the great
american philosopher william james who
spoke about alcohol as the first
uh level of mystical consciousness even
going on to ether nitrous oxide and so
on so forth
and then um i should mention before that
the great cornishman huffy davey
who lived around here in penzance who
tried nitrous oxide and
and related to philosophy uh idealism
and so on
so there was this intellectual president
of um psychoactive drugs at least in
in britain but then um you had the sort
of legacy of
certain religious frameworks that caused
prohibition and then
timothy leary caused a bit of a sort of
commotion in america and
which then um sort of um got trans
muted to the whole world and um
but but alcohol tobacco and a few other
drugs they were made
um they were maintained as legal and um
you know now as david nutt actually has
shown in sight with empirical evidence
these
drugs are actually more harmful than
many of the psychedelic drugs which are
class a
are scheduled um here so the science
no longer um maps on to the law
the logic based on history doesn't map
on
um to the law and then also i would say
that do you see
drugs as criminal or recreational this
is a product of the mid 20th century we
can see them as
medicinal as lsd originally was intended
to be
but also as intellectual and
philosophical metaphysical um
has metaphysical sort of values as well
so
one hopes that the law will change to
match um
reason and science but i i would also
say this there are a lot of other
ethical considerations for example if
you immediately
legalized all drugs you get into other
problems for example scarcity of certain
cacti
toads and so on you know so it's
actually you know it's not a
black and white issue it has to be
carefully done
have the west's economic interest been
central to its attitude to other nations
recreational drugs is it all about
economics is it all about the
alcohol and tobacco industries do you
think deirdre i don't
think so um it
it's certainly true that the opium wars
were they they were
economic in in character and and
and of the absurd obsession with the
with the with with the
balance of trade among india and china
and britain
but for modern prohibition i think we
have to
uh point
to my own um country and it's
on again off again um
puritanical obsessions
i mean my country like yours
is a free country but every once in a
while
we want to get the state in there and
force people to do
things and uh what's odd about the
history of
drug prohibition
is that it starts in the united states
um
cocaine against
american african-americans in the early
20th century um marijuana
prohibition against hispanic americans
and then of course we try the the noble
experiment
of uh alcohol prohibition which
as has been pointed out was a
catastrophe
and then in the 1930s one particular guy
i forget his name said
yeah that's right we have to do this for
drugs
politically people like
pro
individually they hate it yeah so david
do you think it's all about puritanism
or do you think it's about the economic
interests
of perhaps the alcohol and tobacco
industry it started
well yes it's it's complicated to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you